Mark good to have you with us so
President Biden is at Winfield house
with the U.S ambassador for the night
he's gonna have meetings tomorrow and
then on to a very consequential NATO
Summit in Lithuania
yeah a very very busy beginning of the
week for President Biden and for all 31
uh leaders of the countries that make up
NATO the first uh event for the
president tomorrow will be Downing
Street it's his first visit incidentally
as president to Downing Street he's met
Rishi sunak
once a month for the past six months but
since he's become president he's not
been to Downing Street itself so there
will be key talks at Downing Street with
the Prime Minister where they will
discuss Ukraine for sure that will be
front and center in the afternoon he
will go to Windsor Castle there will be
a um a guard of Honor by the Welsh
guards in the uh quadrangle outside
Windsor Castle and then talks with the
king the first time again that he has
has met the first time he's met the king
as king they know each other for over
many years but not not as king and
president
um there the focus I think will be
climate change an issue that um is a key
Focus for both men and so we can expect
perhaps a like they're coming together
of mind and perhaps using their
influence to make some difference on
issues of climate change and then
Vilnius then Lithuania then the um the
summit itself the NATO Summit Rishi
sunak and the president will both travel
there where the focus will of course be
the war in Ukraine uh there will be
focuses on the custom Munitions decision
by the Americans uneased by other
European and NATO countries simply
because they are signatories to Cluster
Munitions Banning conventions uh that
the Americans are not I don't think that
though will will upset the summit I
think there's a recognition by all NATO
countries that while they'd rather not
have these weapons on the battlefield
the Americans have them there is a
supply shortage Ukraine's
counter-offensive is not going all that
well that's not to say that the Russians
are doing well but the Ukraine neither
side is doing well and there needs to be
a break in the um uh in the on the
battlefield and these weapons will be
will be very very effective the other
issue I think will be the membership of
Sweden to you uh to Nato uh being
blocked at the moment by Turkey in it's
interesting that just a few hours ago
the president President Biden and
president erdogan of Turkey spoke on the
phone they will have discussed Swedish
membership to Nato and I think other
issues will have came up as well uh the
uh the um Turkish want to become uh
members of the European Union and I know
that uh president erdogan brought that
up uh with President Biden and also the
issue of F-16 fighter jets which the
Turkish want President Biden May well
sell them to to Turkey all of these
issues are linked because uh deals will
be done behind the scenes if if NATO
wants something out of turkey perhaps
they'll give them uh something else so
an awful lot to discuss at a very key
NATO Summit it is 500 days now more than
that that this war has been going on
they will reflect on those past 500 days
they will try to forge a path for the
coming months as well